Step aside, L'Oreal - cause space travel is
the new breakthrough in anti-aging.
Hey guys Tara here for DNews - talking about
an interesting new study from NASA, designed
to study the effects of long-term space travel
on the human body.
The guinea pigs they're using are Scott and
Mark Kelly - two identical twin brothers,
who also happen to be astronauts.
In March 2015, NASA will send one of the twins,
Scott, on a one-year mission to the International
Space Station, where he will spend a full
365 days circling the earth at 17,000 MPH.
His twin brother Mark, a now retired astronaut,
will stay behind, as the control subject.
NASA's Human Research Program will take samples
and measurements of the twins before, during,
and after the mission.
And they've selected 10 different research
proposals, each studying a different biological
effect of space travel.
One of the proposals focuses on the immune
system, which is typically suppressed in space.
So for that experiment, Mark and Scott will
be given identical flu vaccines - and then
examined to see how their immune systems react
to it.
Some of the other proposals focus on things
like gut health, vision - which typically
changes in space - and a phenomenon called
"space fog", which is a lack of mental clarity
typically experienced by astronauts in orbit.
They'll also be looking at the effects of
space travel on aging, and specifically, telomeres
- which are the little caps on the end of
your chromosomes that prevent them from deteriorating
or fusing with other chromosomes.
The loss or shortening of telomeres is typically
associated with more rapid aging, and it's
theorized that exposure to cosmic rays in
space - could shorten these telomeres, causing
someone to prematurely age while in orbit.
This harkens back to Einstein's "Twin Paradox"
theory, which is an old thought experiment
that says if one identical twin travels into
space on a high-speed rocket, and the other
stays home, the twin who went into space should
actually return younger than his brother - according
to the theory of relativity.
We already know that clocks traveling at a
high speed, measure time differently - that's
called "time dilation" - so it's only logical
that that should apply to humans as well,
since we're are all governed by our own internal
clock.
Unfortunately, the Twin Paradox theory only
holds - if the twin in space, is approaching
the speed of light - which is around 40,000
times faster than what the ISS currently travels
at.
So, NASA may never be able to test that.
Which is why for this experiment, they're
focusing on more realistic aging effects,
like the telomere one.
Either way, I think this is a fascinating
experiment - and I'm especially looking forward
to seeing what cognitive effects a year of
space travel has on you - if only to feel
better about my own rapidly deteriorating
mind.
And hey - if you have any interesting theories
about what might happen to these guys - let
us know in the comments down below, and subscribe
here for more Dnews.